d'apparence ordinaire ce bus le mobile
office est en réalité une pépite
technologique à l'intérieur ses
utilisateurs peuvent se connecter à
leurs réseaux d'entreprise et même
réaliser des visioconférences sans
coupure de réseau
ce concept est équipé un bus de moyens
de télécommunications sécurisées pour
permettre un soin de faire une connexion
pendant tout le trajet mais aussi
d'avoir des connexions particulière vers
les réseaux de l'entreprise ont une
qualité de réseau assurée par airbus
pour un projet développé par ce moving
une start-up saint-quentinoise missionné
de trouver des solutions pour attirer
les jeunes ingénieurs vers ces sites
extérieurs à paris sans perdre de temps
c'est tout le propre de la première
expérimentation qu'on souhaiterait
lancer pour sur une période de six mois
en début d'année ce sera effectivement
de pouvoir valider et notamment avec les
relations les ressources humaines des
entreprises concernées cette capacité
qu'auraient les collaborateurs à être
considéré comme sûr le lieu de travail
une première expérimentation qui visait
également à séduire ile-de-france
mobilité pour envisager un test à plus
grande échelle voir une mise en service
réelle de ces bus à aux moyens de
communication les transports du futur
c'est bien sûr au centre de saint
quentin
et en plus la présidente de la région
ile de france est très centré à la
raison porté sur le télétravail sur les
supports numériques aujourd'hui
permettent d'envisager que le temps de
transport en fait soit quasiment dans le
temps de travail objectif mettre en
place une ligne régulière début 2020
pour réaliser tous les tests et
perfectionner nous mobile office aux
ambitions de déploiement international